hello there you're watching the press
preview our first look at what's on the
front pages
as they arrive over the next half an
hour we're going to be talking about the
headlines with the consultant editor of
the daily mail andrew pearce
and the associate editor of the daily
mirror kevin mcguire said good evening
to both of you lovely to see you both
so let's take a look then what's making
the front pages and the daily telegraph
hears that
parents will be asked to test their
secondary school age
children for covert 19 twice a week at
home
in an effort to ensure schools can stay
open
the guardian points out that although
infection rates have fallen
significantly
children are now the group spreading the
virus most widely
the metro understands young adult
volunteers will be paid four and a half
thousand pounds to take part in a study
in which they'll be deliberately
infected with coronavirus to test the
effectiveness of
new vaccines the mirror reports on boris
johnson's promise that lockdown will be
lifted cautiously
and in stages that story is also on the
front of the express with the prime
minister saying decisions will be based
on
data the daily mail says mr johnson is
coming under increasing pressure to lift
the lock down
more quickly and the financial times
reports that the uk's former chief
brexit negotiator lord frost is to join
the cabinet
as a minister responsible for overseeing
the country's relationship
with the eu
so andrew pearce i'm kevin mcguire here
to take us through some of those
headlines
um and andrew you picked out um kevin's
paper first of all very generous of you
the daily mirror
and their headline there small steps to
normal life reflecting what the prime
minister was talking about today
about easing lockdown in stages
this real sense that the caution is the
watch word
yeah it's caution caution all the time
the the language the prime minister is
using is in stark contrast
to the language he used last year when
everything was going to be world beating
it's going to be well beating test and
trace system it was actually third rate
with world beating tests and trace app
that didn't even work
so now the language has changed the
whole approach has changed
i think he was always wanted to be
cautious but there is a natural tendency
in boris johnson to talk
boosterism to be enthusiastic to want to
please so he's
this is all about managing expectations
in my viewana a lot of scientists giving
evidence to mps today saying
we can cut we could come out of lockdown
more rapidly than we did
the first time round because the data is
much better
but the prime minister is going to be
quite clear about this and i think he's
right
this can be the la this has to be the
last lockdown
if we if we come if we come out and then
went back in
that would not just be a political
failure it would be the death of the
economy
it would be catastrophic for the
country's elves so that's why
i think there is caution and although
some of us might think come on prime
minister this is when we need you to be
a bit
bolder a bit more radical i think you
would look if you looked at the opinion
polls
most of those suggest people are with
him uh they don't want us to go
too quickly if they think it's going to
take any risks
with the nation's health well yes and
and kevin tonight our deputy political
editor sam coats has seen some vital
documents with
with a a plan for coming out of lockdown
we don't know whether that's the plan
that the prime minister will end up
adopting but that suggests a relatively
rapid moving out
of lockdown talks about schools going
back in march
further education perhaps mid-april late
april hospitality venues and leisure
facilities that's part of this plan that
he's seen
lots of talk about what might happen
will we find out in detail do you think
on monday or do you think
the prime minister is likely to be still
quite vague when he makes that
announcement
i think there'll be a lot of caveats and
qualifications and
and vagueness but given he is as
andrew said he's normally into this
boosterism you wonder if he's being
sedated
or there's a body double uh taking his
place or is he playing a game
in that he is deliberately lowering
expectations now so he can pull
something out next
next week week after early april and say
look uh
thanks to my great efforts sorry uh said
your great sacrifices but he means my
great efforts
then uh we can do more than more than i
expected so he creates a sense of
of excitement but in the past he always
over promised and it ended up in
disaster
at the beginning in uh march that
lockdown 12 weeks he thought he'd change
it
well we know where we ended up then it
was going to be by christmas back to
normal then at christmas he's having to
rip up his own plans for a kind of free
free-for-all because the virus was
letting rip so it is a very different
tone
from him uh today but again as andrew
says
uh scientists epidemiologists uh you
know professors people who know what
they were talking about were queuing up
really to mps and saying look you can
ease uh he's locked down there's an
edinburgh university uh
epidemiologist who will say look you can
go to the beach you might have seen all
those pictures
of crowded beaches or apparently crowded
beaches last
summer caused an outcry but no evidence
there was any transmission because it's
out of doors so
i do wonder he will he will have to
caveat it and he will have to be
guardable
involve people in a big national
conversation just say look if this
happens we can do that
and of course it's going to be you can't
just say you have a roadmap and we'll
stick to it
if all of a sudden infections go up
hospitalizations go up and deaths go up
but the vaccination does
seem to have changed the game and it
that you know that light at the end of
the tunnel is getting brighter and it's
getting nearer
well yes and let's move on to the daily
telegraph as well andrea shall we
their headline says parents to test
children for covid
twice a week and testing does seem to be
a key to the government's plans for
opening up doesn't it
yeah well good luck with that you know
because they're talking about parents
testing twice a week their children with
these rapid flow tests well
i've had a couple of those they're
pretty damned unpleasant
it involves something which looks like a
knitting needle stuck up your nostrils
uh or you can have a throat swab the
knot the ones up your nostrils
is potentially dangerous if you don't
get it right and if you remember
uh one of gavin williamson the education
secretary
for now uh one of his more bird-brained
ideas was that all
teachers were going to have to test
children when they went back to school
after the christmas break as you recall
they went back to school for one
solitary day
and that all fell apart because uh the
watchdog body
said it wasn't appropriate i think
there'll be some parents that would be
very reluctant about this
how will we know they've done them uh it
it but but you can see
why they're going for this because they
think testing is the answer
they want to and also to that that will
help really assure teachers
who are very anxious of course that they
may be infected
by kids who don't if you see them if you
see them out and about in streets now i
know what
the experts are saying to mps today
you're much less likely to catch the
infection
outdoors just as well because if you see
a group of teenagers
they're all congregating together does
this idea
of testing either for pupils i think
they're talking about secondary school
pupils in in this case but also for
for some workers to be able to return
and
and for some other industries to help
open up does this idea of mass testing
makes sense to you kevin
it does yeah as a principle and it
should have been
pursued rather earlier rather than
abandoned in march or april and
22 billion has been spent on a test and
trade system which is badged as nhs but
isn't
driven by private companies and it's
been pretty much uh
a sort of fatal waste of money but no
regular testing
alongside vaccinations is the way
forward but
parents are going to find it very
difficult i too have had one of these uh
lateral floor tests uh they're not
entirely reliable they're not as
reliable as the pcr
uh test where you your uh sample goes
off to a laboratory they're more you
know
like the i don't know a pregnancy test
uh or they're not as accuracy as a
pregnancy test
but it's very difficult i was going to
go on holiday and i i went and paid my
150 quid didn't get on holiday in the
end the
uh the prime minister changed the rules
i couldn't go but it is very painful
getting these swaps stuck up your nose
properly and down your throat
in order to to get a an accurate sample
i think many parents just
won't be able to do it or won't do it
don't do it properly and it shouldn't be
teachers if you if you're going to do
if you're going to do this properly
you've got to recruit
and train testers who will go to schools
go to workplaces you can't just have diy
tests people doing it themselves or
parents trying to do it on little johnny
or jenny that that won't work but it's
it's it's a good idea but it's how you
implement it and that's what will be
most
most important okay and um tony's the
guardian
andrew more information coming in all
the time on
the effect of lockdown and uh
potentially the effect of vaccination
though hopefully that will become
clearer
when the government shares some of their
data but what's the guardian
saying about what the latest figures
suggest
well this is the figures coming out of
imperia imperial who are in the thick of
all of this suggesting that
more and more children are now spreaders
now of course that's a cause for concern
as we know that the
government is intent that schools will
reopen on march the 8th now
i was under the impression uh that it
would be staggered it would be primary
school children first but this report on
the front page is the guardian saying
it is primary school children who are
spreading it the most
so this is going to be problematic and
this could be why
uh the government is saying that parents
are going to have to test children
and i think it's going to be even more
problematic i mean
i i would struggle to do one of these
rapid flow tests on somebody
imagine if you're a mum or a dad and
you're doing it with your primary school
child
age six or seven that is not going to be
easy
uh and it has it's it's it's frau but
it's another problem
that the government's going to have to
get to grips with do you think is that
how you interpret it um
kevin i mean the the opening paragraph
here talks about coveted infections
falling by two-thirds in a month in
england but the virus now spreading most
amongst primary
age children and young people i mean is
that a reflection on how much it's
fallen in other age groups or what
how do we interpret this well i think
the proportion has gone up because it's
fought it's falling elsewhere but it's
also
i think this this came out when schools
were were shut in england at the
beginning of
january after the government i think
rather foolishly uh was browbeating
teachers and heads and local education
authorities and saying you must
reopen despite uh all concerns being
expressed that kids were spreading it
more than was
acknowledged by the prime minister and
the education
secretary kids they spread knits and
and flew between or coughs and calls
between each other and
any parent knows they bring them home so
that is always going to be the
danger with coronavirus but he wants
schools to reopen because it's so
important on so many levels for kids and
their future
prospects and it's not just what they
learn it's all that socialization and
their mental health
as well and particularly kids in
disadvantaged
homes so you want to know but we've got
to acknowledge there
is a risk and there is a danger and it's
so i'm going to be tackled but
you know these lateral floor tests are
painful they're very uncomfortable
they're not not pleasant so
if andrew needs one again i'll do it to
him
that's such a generous offer he looks
really grateful
i've only ever found them ticklish can i
just say
eg's chopsticks he just chopsticks from
his chinese takeaway
okay i'll let you discuss that during
the break uh and i'll tell you what's
coming up after it the uk's former chief
brexit negotiator lands himself a seat
in the cabinet we're gonna be talking
about that next
you're watching the press preview with
me tonight andrew pearce and kevin
mcguire
and andrew we're starting with the front
page of the ft next aren't we and their
main headline
focuses on uh lord frost who
we got to know the name a lot during
brexit negotiations but he's got a new
job
yeah no he said he was a chief brexit
negotiator he pulled off that deal
uh which people like kevin mcgrath said
would never happen the deal which was
done with the eu on christmas eve or
december the 23rd whenever it was he is
now
uh he got his periods out of it he's now
joining the cabinet as a minister of
state well ministry of states don't
normally
aren't normally cabinet ministers but
he's going to have cabinet status he's
effectively
in my view the whole brexit department
which we had before the department for
exiting the european union is being
recreated
and frost is going to take on the big
job of
sorting out trade deals he's going to
have the poison chalice of sorting out
the
northern ireland protocol which is a
complete mess
and uh and there are other things to
resolve with european unions such as
equivalence in financial affairs because
the trade deal didn't deal with
financial matters which is
a huge part of the british economy and
uh the ft you're saying it's called it's
been there's been a huge
power struggle within the government
well maybe that has maybe hasn't but i
if i was michael gove
who's been handling a lot of this i
think he'll be mighty relieved to be
handing a lot of this over to david
frost david frost is
deeply deeply immersed in the detail as
he's going
of course and he's a brexiteer a
passionate brexiteer
and i think he'll do a great job yeah
the reward for failure is promotion to
the cabinet and taking back control as
an unelected
peer in charge look i never said there
would be no
elected peers in labor's cabinet elected
peers in labour's cabinet
mandelson lord of the longest bad
deal you talk about all the problems
whether it's shellfish exporters going
out of business
or whether it's the northern ireland
problem french
oh dear give me the french
i'm going to move you on i'm thinking
you're not going to find agreement on
that one let's let's move on
and and the daily telegraph has a
picture of prince philip on its front
page
he features on a number of them uh after
the news that he's spending a second
night in hospital
uh tonight andrew but um buckingham
palace has talked about it being
precautionary
and we're we're told he's in he's in
good spirits
yeah look the the the words coming out
of the palace are all very cautionary
uh but nobody can be terribly relaxed a
man of 99
going into hospital particularly in in
days of ko
kovid um you just have to think about
the wonderful captain tom
he went into hospital with pneumonia and
sadly
we lost him now prince philip would
prefer
because we know what he's like he's
curmudgeonly and stubborn
he'd rather be anywhere tonight but in
hospital for a second night
the reassuring thing is her manchester
the queen has stayed in windsor castle
if she was deeply concerned about him i
suspect she'd have moved to buckingham
palace so she could be closer
and he's had no visitors so far but we
wish him well he's 100 in
june and it would be great if he got
there indeed
we all wish him well um kevin we we are
out of time i know you're nodding
and say that you agree with that we know
he doesn't like farsi he probably
wouldn't like the headlines either would
he
um but we are gonna leave it there we're
out of time but i will see you both
again at
11 30. thank you for the moment kevin
and andrew